مساء الخير الصين فيها سبعه وسبعين مليون
اربعمائه تسعه وستين الف شركه حتى يناير
2016 وفقا لوزاره التجاره والصناعه
الصينيه ليه من بين كل هذا العدد المهول
تستهدف الاداره الامريكيه شركه واوه على
وجه التحديد
الاجابه على السؤال ده اقتضى منا اللي
نحنا نعرف الحكايه الحكايه اللي وراء
الحكايه والحقيقه البيره
الحكايه للناس كلها تعرفها ان الاداره
الامريكيه بتتهم الشركه الصينيه بحوزتهم
محدده التهمه الاولى هو محاوله الالتفاف
على العقوبات الامريكيه على ايران متهما
تستوجب بالعقوبه وفقا للقانون الامريكي
التهمه الثانيه
سرقه اسرار تكنولوجيه لشركات امريكيه
وغربيه
التهمه الثالثه والاخطر هي التجسس لصالح
الحكومه الصينيه الفلسطينيه تتهم المدني
هذا دليل على اي من هذه الطرق اثبتوا مثلا
ان احنا تستثني على اي حكومه في العالم
ونحن نعمل في اسواق كثيره الامريكان مش
حتى الان دليل محدد خصوصا على تهمه التجسس
ولكن ابسط موقف او ابسط يعني افضل رد يعبر
عن الموقف الامريكي اللي جاء على لسان احد
اعضاء مجلس النواب الامريكي لا لون
باختصار كدا وبصراحه انتم متهمون لانك
مسينيون شركه صينيه والصين خصم ومنافس
الينا وبالتالي يصعب علينا جدا اننا من
على او من الامن القومي وامن وحلفائنا مع
شركه صينيه يضعوا امنهم القومي في يد شركه
او
اشتغل فيه مجال البالغه الحساسيه
وهو مجال شبكات الهواتف المحموله وبالتالي
مجال المعلومات
الاتهامات الامريكيه عقوبات كثيره نقدر ن
الخاص هكذا على طريقه كفار قريش
اليهم ولا نشتري منهم فمنعوا الشركه من
دخول السوق الامريكي ممارسه ضغوط على
حلفائهم في اوروبا في اليابان وفي
استراليا من عدم استخدام او عدم التعامل
مع شركه وهي بيحلوا ينجحوا احيانا ويفشلوا
احيانا يعني في مقومه للضغوط الامريكيه من
جانب حلفائها الامر الثاني من الشركات
الامريكيه اللي بتزود ومكونات وبرامج من
التعامل معها بعد 19 اغسطس المقبل الا
باذن من السلطات الامريكيه
الشركه الامريكيه من جانبها ردت وردت على
كل المستويات
كان فيه كثير من التحدي تحديدا بيمثلوا
تصريحات المسؤولين الشركه ورئيسها الاول
للرئيس الامريكي والاداره الامريكيه
لهذا اليوم كنا نستعين انتم لا تقدرون قوه
شركه
وبدؤوا يهدوا باكثر من اسلوب الاسلوب
الاول يعني الاسلوب اللي هو مقاضاه
الاداره الامريكيه او القرارات الامريكيه
داخل المحاكم الامريكيه محاوله التفاوض
والاقناع ويقولوا نهمل وستون ان تستبدل ون
الذي هو ادنى بالذي هو خير وتروح والشركات
تكون خدمه اقل سعر اكبر ثم التهديد
التهديد
على اكثر من جانب منه العلوم انا لا ادري
اذا كنت بتقولوا لي ان اندرويد الان
ابتدوا من جوجل يؤثر عليها انا في سبتمبر
المقبل اطلع تلفون الجديد في نظام تشغيل
جديد وانتم مشاكل واحد يشتروا من
الان رايه وانا عندي اذا كنت بتقولوا
للشركات اللي هي الديني اشباه الموصلات او
السمك وندرس
وغيرها وانا اشتري منكم ب 11 مليار دولار
في السنه مش اشتري من قبل حداشر مليار
ابحث عن بدائل وانا اطور قدراته الذاتيه
ثم
الاكثر من ذلك انه بدا التهديد من جانب
الحكومه الامريكيه من جانب الحكومه الاسف
من جانب الحكومه الصينيه اللي بتدعم شاركت
واولهم اذا كنتم انتوا تحولوا الضرب اهم
شركاته في مجال التكنولوجيا
فانا لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي وانا اخذ
عقوبات على شركات اخرى زي فيليكس قبل
والاخطر من كده ان هددت الامريكان او
الواحد الامريكان بوضع قيود على تصدير ما
يسمى بلير
او لعناصر الاردن قدرنا اللي هما سبعطاشر
عنصر كما وي بتدخل فيه كثير جدا من
الصناعات الحيويه
سواءا ولديه الطاقه الهوائيه صناعه
السيارات صناعه الزجاج صناعه الالكترونيات
كثير جدا صناعه الاسلحه وقالت لهم ودي
الصين تحتكر او بدون اكثر من سبعين في
المائه منها على وجه الكره الارضيه
والامريكان ب يعتمد اعتماد اساسي على
الواردات الصينيه من هذه العناصر المهمه
صارت لهم اذا كنتم نوعا للتكنولوجيا اللي
هي بتقوم على العناصر اللي انا ب صدرها
لكم ايه المال عن الامن عنكم هذه الواردات
والحرب سجال ما هي الحكايه الناس بتعرف ها
الشركه الكبيره الامريكان بيحولوا هي حرب
وهاو اضغطوا عليها ومحاولات الشركه للتحدي
وللتاكيد لكل الناس اننا
انما تصل وراء الحكي اكبر من كذا واقع
الامر ان الولايات المتحده تستهدف هو ممكن
سببين اساسيين اولا سبب يتعلق بالمجال
اللي تعمل فيه شركه واوه والسبب الثاني
النووي الشركه تعمل في مجال حساس وهي شركه
صينيه يعني جنسيتها المدني تتعمل بالنسبه
يعرفه عنوان هي بتلك الهام سته
والتليفونات اللي في ادين الناس اللي ما
تعيش الامريكان كثير خصوصا انه كمان
شركه وفي مجال الهواتف المحموله محدود في
امريكا ولو بقي كبير بردو مش مشكله لكن ما
يعني الولايات المتحده وتفوق في مجال
شبكات المحمول وتحديدا في مجال الجيل
الخامس اللي يستحق منا حلقه ثانيه لانه
موضوع كبير جدا لكن لو حبينا الى خطوره
المساله خطوره المساله باختصار زي ما
وضعها عدد من الخبراء منهم الدكتور احمد
بهاء خبرنا المحترم في التكنولوجيا
والدكتور خالد شريف بردو احد خبرائنا
المهمين في التكنولوجيا انه القصه بايجاز
شديد جدا
شرطه واوه هي رقم واحد في مجال الشركات في
العالم وهي الرائده في مجال الجيل الخامس
تاجيل الخمس احنا لسه في مثلا في بلدنا في
مصر الجيل الثالث ومعظم الدول العربيه في
كل التالف وبعضهم بدا يدخل الى الكل
الرابع لكن مفيش حد في العالم حتى الان
دخل الى الخامس اللي هو على الاعتاب اللي
يحتكر التكنولوجيا
يحتكر اللي ب يتفوق فيها هي شركه ما لهاش
منافسين امريكان وزي ما بيقولوا الدكتور
بهاء واحمد بدير تروح لشركه هواوي هي افضل
من يقدمها التكنولوجيا وبافضل الاسعار
طيب اي مشكله ان يكون شركه متفوقه خصوصا
انه ما فيش منافسين الامريكان المنافسين
الباقيين اوروبيين وصينيين المشكله انه من
يملك التفوق في مجال الجيل الخامس يملك
اذا ما كانش القول النهائي القول المؤثر
في كثير جدا من التكنولوجيا الرقميه
الاخرى لصناعه الالكترونيات
وبالتالي السيطره او المدخل الاساسي يملك
القناه الاساسيه اللي يكلف منها او الها
دخل منها او هي تكون المعبر الاساسي
الاقتصاد القرن الواحد وعشرين
اقتصاد القرن الواحد وعشرين
ونسيت واخشاب
الصناعات التقليديه اللي يحدد وصول اقتصاد
القرن الواحد وعشرين اهم على ما يسمى
بالثوره الصناعيه الرابعه ثوره رقميه
ماهوله اقرب لفيلم الخيال العلمي كل شيء
على اساس
اللي تنقلها الانترنيت من اول الفشل اللي
بتحطها فى الكهرباء حجم الاستهلاك العربيه
اللي بتتكلم مع اكو بتكلم الناس والقياده
ذاتيه للصواريخ الفرسان كل الاجهزه الطبيه
اللي تعمل عمليه تشخيص تلقائي بشكل متطور
جدا ل
اه ال اه اه طبعا ثلاثيه الابعاد اللي تحط
مده هنا في مصر على طياره او
سياره في اثيوبيا
لصناعه كل شيء الثوره الصناعيه الرابع
اللي هي بتمثل مستقبل الاقتصاد في القمه
الواحد والعشرين
بالاساس على توفر سرعه انترنت
17 ضعف الثوره ال ال ال ال الجيل الرابع
اللي حنا دخلنا هو بيبقى سبعطاشر ضعف
الجيل الرابع هوايا عندها مفاتيح هذه ال
الجيل الخامس هذه الثوره المدخل الى القرن
الواحد والعشرين اذا سمحت لها الولايات
المتحده يبقى هي
حتى الحركتين فتحت الباب للصين انها تكون
اكثر واكثر تفوقا من ما هي عليه الان وخسر
السباق في الجيل الخامس وكل التكنولوجيات
والاقتصادات اللي تقوم عليه وهذا ضعف
وبالتالي هي بتعمل اكبر قدر ممكن من
الجهود كل ما تعتقد انه هو ممكن يعطل شركه
ليس لان الولايات المتحده ضد الجيل الخامس
والثوره اسماعيل 4 طبعا ولكن لانه وهي
شركه صينيه يعني بتمثل من الكابوس الصيني
للامريكان حبينا هو الكابوس الصيني
للامريكان تطور سريع جدا جدا ومفاجئ لم
يستطع الامريكان استيعابه وحتى الان
مثاليا صغيره مثلا يتعلق الصين كدوله وما
يتعلق ب شركه واول اللي احنا بنتكلم عن
سنه تسعه وسبعين يعني من حوالي اربعين سنه
المحلي الاجمالي
كلها دوله كوكب الصين ده كله امنيه ثمانيه
وسبعين مليار دولار فقط لا غير عشان تعرف
عنده متواضعا بدايه بالنسبه للحج والصين
المهول نقرب دوله لا تبلغ عشر عدد سكانها
وهي لا بان جارتها اللدوده كان في هذا
العام الناتج المحلي الاجمالي اليابان
اليوم وخمسه وخمسين مليار دولار
اما الولايات المتحده فكان الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي ليها
يتجاوز الاثنين وسته من عشره بليون دولار
يعني لا يوجد وجه للمقارنه في 2018 اصبح
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للصين بالارقام
المؤمل الاسميه اربعطاش ثلاثه من عشره
مليون دولار والولايات المتحده واحد
وعشرين
الشريعه الواحد وعشرين مليون دولار
بالارقام اللي هو القوه الشرائيه معادله
القوه الشرعيه اللي تكلمنا عنه في حالات
هل تصبح مصر سبعه اكبر اقتصاد في العالم
لن ترجع ولو الولايات الم الصين المعيار
ده ال الجيد المحلي الاجمالي ليها سبعه
وعشرين اليوم اكثر من سبعه وعشرين مليون
دولار يعني متفوقه على الولايات المتحده
حوالي سته مليون دولار ففي يعني في خلال
اربعين سنه حسب تطور كبير جدا والتطور ده
مجاش الاول الامريكان مش القليل منه لانه
كان جاي من اقتصادات تقليديه سماعه
وسيارات بسيطه مش معقده
قطارات وزراعه الان الولاء الصين وفق
الخطط ها
الفين وخمسه وعشرين هي تستهدف كل ما يتعلق
بتكنولوجيا الجيل الخامس بكل مكوناتها
يبقى عندها الشركات اللي هي متفوقه فيها
وعندها المكونات اللي اتخذها من امريكا
صناعه في الصين وكمان بقى عندها مشغلين
يعدلوا بدا فون و اي تي ان تي اللي هي
الشركه الامريكيه عندها كل الادوات التي
تمكنها من السيطره على اقتصاد الذي على
اقتصاد القرن ال 21 الواوي بتلعب في الدور
الاكبر
فالمساله مش مجرد ان الشركه يعني خلاف
تجاري بسيط او ميزان التجاري او بتصدر لنا
اكثر ما ب تستورد من هنا المساله تتعلق
بالمستقبل و بنفوذ
وكيان الولايات المتحده
لما نشوف بردو الو او اللي بتمثل كابوس
هلا ان هي زي الصين 2000 و 2001 الشركه
اساسات سنه سبعه وثمانين مات واحد يسمع شو
كانت مجرد يعني شركه بتكلم عن هذا هو حاجه
بسيطه كان الان شرطه و وهي ثاني اكبر شركه
في العالم في مجال الاجهزه المحموله بعد س
امسك وتخطط انهى تتجاوز خمسه قريبا وهي
رقم واحد ب براءات الاختراع الكبيره جدا
اللي عملتها في مجال الشركات في العالم
بدون منازع
في سنه الفين وتسعه فتره العالم ان
العوائد بتاعتها عشرين مليار دولار فيلم
18 تجاوزت المائه مليار دولار يعني مائه
وسبعه مليار دولار وعنده
جدا لتحقيق انجازات كثيره
الكلام عن الماضي ياخذنا عن المجال اخر
مهم جدا في اطار حدثت على النظام العالمي
الجديد وهو الصراع الحرب البارده ولكن
الحرب التكنولوجيه اللي تك تنحصر مابين
الولايات المتحده والصين بالدرجه الاولى
ثم اطراف اخرى زي
التحتيه روسيا وبعض الدول الاوروبيه
واليابان اشكركم والى لقاء اخر ان شاء
الله
[موسيقى]